Muzeu etnografik ësht një banes tradicjonale ndërtuar në mesin e shëjkullit të të tëmbëdhjetë
1764, gëka plan pashtë të optani.
Arkhitektura e saj është orientale me koridor të mbëlur,
tip kule du katëshë me mure guri me gjerësi 60-90 cm.
Në të, gjendën piktura të stilit barok dhe islamik të cilat zbukurojnë dhomat kresore të saj.
Cë në hërëje bjen në suharchete portave me gurë të gëdhendur dhe rugë të ështruara me kaldrëm.
Në këtë banes, gjendën shumë elemente të traditës sezonës
për mënure në jetesës, dhejshjes, zakoneve, et të tjera.
Në hërëje janë disa modele burimësh naturale të ujit të cilat dëshmojnë se kurja ka patur disa të tila,
madje mendoet se dhe prejardhja ejmëj të cjutetit vjen gëa fjale a kroje, që do të të thot kuri në shivë.
Në holin e katit të par njësh me vedle traditionale të bujkutë për punimin e tokës,
mekanizme të bluarje se dritit me dorë dhe me ujë, mekanizme të pastrimit të grurit për hashure, et të tjera.
Njëngë a zejë të ekspozuara rë shrejgja, ose për punimi lë kurës dhe për cejset që kalon të ajo,
për dorur më pas për të bër këpuz.
Gjithashtun në ambjente të baneses, njësh me për punimin e kaštë se kënetës
dhe përdhimin e haastrave për të ullur ose për të fjetur.
Në puniste të katit të par do shikoni puniste në kupunoi hekuri për nevojate familjes dhe të tregu të krujes
si dhe cëramika kuprëdo eshë në tjegula, tula dhe objekte të përdorimi të pjak.
Në puniste në tjetër do shikoni distillerin kuprëdo e rakhja dhe vera.
Në një puniste tjetër në dode të mulliri me uji për dorur për të bluarë dritin,
valantëja që për dorëj për të bër shajak ose stof leshi
dhe për punimi i leshi të deles për dorur për të bër që leshet.
Në puniste në fundit në dode të mulliri i vajit të ulirit dhe shumë amfora
ose magrit për dorur për të mbajtur për një kod të gjat vajit në ulirit.
Në katin e du të baneses,
filoet nga dhoma e grave ose e nusës,
ku dalohen arkat ku nusja sil të paja në saj, të cilat janë originale,
pikturat murale të shjekuli të të tëmbëdhjet dhe du tipe dritare shë të veqanta me punim druri,
të cilat larë të janë me punimi gjipsi vetëm për drit dhe posh për ajerosje.
Koridori që shërben sinderlides me sdomave ku dhe të shikonje dhe vejshet e dasmes për dhendrin dhe nusën,
i cili eshë mëndaf shi qendisur me arë dhe argjen me për lalumëj.
Nje veqanti eshë se të gjitha dyrët janë të ulta të cilat të detrurojn të ulësh kokën në shenjë respektin në chtë dhomë,
sahër do të futësh apo të dalësh nga jo dhomë.
Oda e burave, me e bukura dhe më interesantja,
eshë të gjitha originali e shjekuli të të tëmbëdhjet.
Në brendësi do shikoni t'avanin, armët e ekspozuara në mur,
o gjakun që ërsh në krahun tjetër të murit në dhomen e familjes.
Do shikoni tëavanin në formë ku pole nëmbuluar me djamë
dhe vrimat në muren nga kudilë të avuli.
Në dhomen e ndenjes, eshë pjesa e balkonit lardë kumbani në familjes që të mosfulejshin për të ngrën me të rituridh,
o gjaku që ngrël dhomen dhe një kosishtvui në hamamidh
dhe gjithashtu vedli në përdorur për të bër qilimet.
Kujina ka një o gjak original tip aspiratori,
entë ndrysh me ceramike, bakr dhe dru.
Gjithashtu kujina eshë përdorur edhe si dhom fjetjeje për më të vjetrit e familjes.
Në dalje do të shikoni veglete marangozit dhe rozeta të avanin bitreqin vjeqare.
Gjithashtu do të shikoni qilarin, dhoma e konservimit të frutave dhe përimeve përdimrin.
Në dhomen e madhe të gjumit janë ekspozuar vëyshe të tradites katolike dhe muslimane,
të përdorura në qitetin e krujes ose të ardhër nga banore të zonave të tjera.